when is the last time you thought you
did a really bad show when was the loss
anything pop into your mind the last
time I had a bad show it wasn't a bad
show that's that's dangerous sometimes
the show is good but the day you just
don't match with the audience it could
be like New York City was rainy and
shitty and the audience doesn't feel
good and you know so so sometimes the
show is good you know that the show is
good but the audience is shitty but the
audience doesn't feel what you're
feeling when those quiet moments occur
and it doesn't necessarily mean you're
not being funny but you may be saying
something just intriguing yes do you get
nervous that that you're tanking no I've
had to learn and that's where Dave
Chappelle was um has been a wonderful
friend and mentor
what did Chappelle say to you that
helped you would sir Paulo said to me we
were we were doing a show at Radio City
together it was during his run right and
I was I was on one of the shows and he
said to me I said man I'm like what am I
gonna tell these cuz I was like I'm
gonna do comedy before Dave Chappelle's
like Dave what am I even doing here yeah
and they said and I said I don't even
know if I'm funny enough to be yesterday
you're nice and I think I'm a really
funny guy but what am I doing here Dave
said look man he said you don't
understand something he said you're not
here because you're funny he says I know
a hundred funny [ __ ] out there
he said you're here because you're
interesting and he said anyone can be
funny not everybody can be interesting
not everyone can make an audience listen
to what they're saying
not everyone has a wealth of life
experience that makes people want to
know what they have in their minds and
so that changed my perspective on
silence and so now if I can hear that an
audience is listening I'm engaged
well that is a great piece of advice not
only for comics but for anybody right
because Wow the thing that I love about
Chappelle and you just identified it is
he will go he's interesting he isn't
interesting the note he's the most
interesting man I've ever met that's
that's yeah that's what makes Dave
Chappelle people many people are funny
there's a lot of funny stand-up
comedians all over the world yes but
what makes Dave Chappelle Dave Chappelle
is that he is interesting it's how he
sees the world between the jokes